so also ich habe folgendes Thema
mitgebracht weil es meiner Meinung nach
komplett untergegangen ist und das darf
auf gar keinen Fall sein am 16 September
ist ein paar Tage zwei Jahre diesen
Jahres natürlich hat die Partei des
ungarischen Ministerpräsidenten Orban
ein ziemlich überraschendes Gesetz
erlassen die eine Abtreibung erschwert
bzw aus meiner Sicht sogar richtig
grotesk macht denn es verlangt
tatsächlich von der Frau dass sie sich
die Herztöne des Babys anhören muss dies
wiederum ärztlich bescheinigen lassen
muss bevor sie dann den schweren Weg
eine Abtreibung gehen darf und die
Begründung dazu die finde ich
noch schlimmer den Frauen würde auf
dieser Weise klar gemacht werden dass es
sich um ein Lebewesen handelt so das ist
für mich absolut unwürdig
Herr Boss ist ganz Grundschule ja ich
wollte was mich nämlich total
interessiert hat als ich dieses Thema
auf dieses Thema gestoßen bin war
kannten sie das Thema kennen sie das
Thema kennen Sie diese Entscheidung
ich kannte sie bis heute nicht auch mit
den Details
gelesen ja und gelesen ja und das fanden
sie doch heute Abend nicht
wichtiges Thema dickes Thema ja also ich
persönlich finde natürlich dass eine
Abtreibung jemand eine Niederlage ist
für beide Parteien also für den Menschen
heranwächst und für die Frau die sich
dazu entscheidet also ich finde jede
Abtreibung ist ist eine Tragödie
letztlich und hat hat keine Gewinner
andererseits ist es für ein liberalen
Rechtsstaat und da muss man natürlich
bei Ungarn ein Fragezeichen dran machen
schwierig da jetzt allzu intensiv da in
die Freiheitsrechte einzugreifen
generell finde ich Abtreibungen immer
immer schlimm und naja also sie meinen
das ist halt Ungarn und dann das ist
Ungarn Sache so jetzt mal ganz salopp
gesagt auf der anderen Seite habt Ungarn
ja gerade eine
anti-abteilungskampagne mit EU gelernt
finanziert also ein bisschen sitzen wir
schon im gemeinsamen Boot finde ich und
der Grund warum ich das Frage ist nicht
weil ich jetzt irgendwie
Verantwortung hin und herschieben möchte
sondern einfach nur weil ich mich dieses
Thema was so wichtig ist werden halt von
so dominanten Männern entschieden und
das wundert mich halt auch sehr sehr
stark warum wird da keine Frau
hinzugezogen warum ist es kein
Frauenthema warum verschwindet das warum
ist es heute Abend nicht hier
aufgegangen
ich könnte aber auch die Gegenfrage
stellen warum ist noch nie das Thema
aufgerufen worden dass in einem
wohlhabenden Land wir in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland jedes Jahr
10.000 Kinder nicht geboren werden
sondern abgetrieben werden wieso regt
sich darüber keine auf wieso ist das
hier kein Thema
Ungarn hat im Prinzip das gleiche Recht
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
nämlich eine Fristenlösung mit
beratungswang aber wir wären
richtigerweise in Deutschland nicht auf
die Idee gekommen eine solche Regelung
einzuführen wie jetzt das ungarische
Parlament das wird auch nicht kommen
Weise allerdings darauf und die
verschiedenen hat das gelesen in meinem
Buch dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt hat dass ungeborene Leben hat die
gleiche Wertigkeit wie das geborene und
wir sind hier in dem Spannungsfeld
zwischen dem Selbstbestimmungsrecht der
Frau und dem Lebensrechtes noch
ungeborenen Kindes aber mit einer
Entwürdigung so haben sie es ja gerade
charakterisiert werden werden wir leben
nicht mehr schützen dass meine
Überzeugung sondern mit Hilfsangeboten
indem man die schwanger auch ermutigt
das Kind alles so tragen und sie in der
Not nicht alleine lässt und dann haben
wir uns nichts vormachen an dieser Not
sind auch auf die Jungs Schuld wir haben
Anfang dabei waren aber dann nichts mehr
damit zu tun haben wollen und ihre
schwangere Frau oder Freundin alleine
lassen in der Not und umso wichtiger
wäre Hilfe ich finde ich stimme ja da
absolut zu dass es gut ist dass es eine
Beratung vorher gibt die gibt es ja auch
in Ungarn es gibt die gibt es auch in
Deutschland das ist keine Frage aber
alles was hier drüber weggeht und da
sind wir hier bei dem sich die Herztöne
anhören müssen ist natürlich grotesk für
die Frau weil nur wenn ich das oder eine
Statistik zu kennen aber ich gehe davon
aus dass nur eine Minderheit einfach so
abtreibt und damit locker umgehen kann
ich habe das heute mal nachgeschaut die
meisten Frauen sind wirklich älter und
es ist auch oft gar nicht das erste Kind
also das Bild von der 18-Jährigen die
geschont werden muss und die nicht
weiter weiß das ist so natürlich auch da
aber nicht so existent es sind vor allem
die älteren und nicht die ganz Jungen
mit den Abtreibung finanzielle Angst ist
eine große Sache dann der Partner der
Ehe stimmt nicht das ist auch noch ein
großes Thema wurde oft das Grund
angegeben und
das ist dann ist es ja schön die Frau
wird danach nicht aufgefangen das kann
ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen ich habe
zwei Fehlgeburten durchgemacht und weiß
wie das ist man wird danach einfach
wieder losgelassen und man wird nicht
aufgefangen das finde ich auch gerade in
ein Land wie Deutschland wahnsinnig zu
bemängeln das ist sehr sehr schade
nichtsdestotrotz geht's ja hier jetzt um
dieses Thema wie kann man sowas
entscheiden und das ist jetzt keine
vorwurfragen sondern eine
Verständnisfrage wie kommt jemand auf so
etwas so etwas zu entscheiden da ist da
doch eigentlich behandelt man somit auch
die Frau als zweite Klasse hätte diese
Reiter ist eine gute Frage warum geht
ein Politiker wie Orban zurück das ist
ja ein Zurückgehen eigentlich also
zunächst einmal bin ich Frau würde ich
sehr dankbar dass sie dieses Thema heute
haben hier
platziert
ich selbst hatte auch nicht viel von
diesem Thema mitbekommen wir reden
derzeit viel über Ungarn aber in einem
anderen Zusammenhang der Streit mit der
Europäischen Union wir reden viel über
das Thema Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Ungarn
wir reden weil die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
in Ungarn tatsächlich auch in Gefahr ist
und natürlich das Thema
Korruptionsbekämpfung in Ungarn das ist
derzeit ein riesen Thema verbunden auch
mit beihilfezahlungen die dann oder
Zahlung der Europäische Union die
derzeit gestoppt werden da bis Ungarn
auch
gewisse Lenkungsmaßnahmen vornimmt die
Debatte ich wusste dass eine solche
Debatte in Ungarn gibt aber die Details
waren mir nicht bekannt die habe ich
erst vor der Sendung einmal gegoogelt
und gelesen also an der Stelle vielen
Dank wir machen uns grundsätzlich große
Sorgen
was Herr urban insgesamt in Ungarn für
eine Politik betreibt und das ist etwas
was man auf völlig unterschiedlichen
Feldern beobachten kann es gibt Leute
die sagen das ist jetzt übertrieben wie
das in Resteuropa gesehen wird andere
sagen in Europa insgesamt sind
europäische Bürgerrechte und auch
Menschenrechte in Gefahr weil urban und
sein systemobern so muss man das auch
zwischen sagen sich auch deutlich
derzeit von den Werten Europas entfernt
von daher wundert mich das auch nicht
dass man Debatten dieser Art hat aber
insgesamt waren unsere Debatten eher bis
jetzt fokussiert auf die politischen
Themen die zu dem was Sie gesagt haben
zu der Zahl der Abtreibung ich glaube
ist wieder leicht angestiegen in
Deutschland und wir haben natürlich hier
schon den Wertungswiderspruch dass wir
einerseits eine relativ stabile Zahlen
Abtreibung haben und andererseits aber
auch sehr viele ungewohnt kinderlose
Paare also ich finde es wäre gut wenn
man
verspricht ich finde das generell
schwierig wenn die Betroffenen nicht
dabei sind wie kommen die dazu so etwas
zu entscheiden dann würde ich lieber mit
Ihnen diskut